What I've got plotted here and
sort of a notional plot,
this is a loss, expected loss, right?
On the left hand side, that's the
probability that it's a four given an x
times the loss of that it's a four and
I call it a nine.
Over here, this is the probability
that it's a nine, but
I actually called it a four.
And the decision boundary is where
these values are equal to one another.
And of course, what is hard about this?
Well, knowing what the losses are,
that's easy, okay?
You just tell me, right?
You tell me, how expensive is it for
me to call a smart person not so
smart versus calling a not so
smart person smart,
will probably have something
to do with their stature.
Okay?
So my losses might be asymmetric,
or my losses might be symmetric.
Like, I'm doing zip codes, right?
And if I call a four, a nine you know,
it goes to California and
it should have gone,
what starts with four?
What zip codes start with four?
I have no idea.
I don't know, let's say Forest, Texas.
So, if I called it a four and
it really was a nine,
it's supposed to go to California,
it goes to Texas.
If I call it a, etc., it goes to te.
So assuming that it's not any worse
ending up in Texas than it is, or
ending up in California, which is
a difficult assumption, I understand.
See there are more people in
California than there are Texas, so
I have to in, so
my loss of insulting Texas is lower than
my loss of insulting Cal, oh nevermind.
Okay, getting back to this.
So I know what my losses are.
The thing that I don't
know is the probabilities.
Right?
For a given x,
how do I actually know what
the probability is that it's a four?
I have to somehow learn that or
know that.
So who's going to help me?